la diversité à l'écran a encore un bon
bout de chemin à faire mais elle se voit
de plus en plus je pense qu'il ya quand
même un mouvement important il ya
vraiment quelque chose qui est en train
de se placer tranquillement
selon une analyse de radio-canada dans
les dix séries télé les plus regardées
en 2018 dont district 31 l'heure bleue
aux échappées et unités 9 près de 11%
des rôles ont été joués par des
personnes assises et tout près du taux
de 13% de personnes issues des minorités
visibles pour l'ensemble du québec y
manque la dernière marche accès à ces
rôles si bien écrit dont le public tombe
dans amoureux c'est ce qui manque pour
l'instant la dernière marche
c'est très agréable hier en effet ce
sont encore les comédiens blancs qui ont
droit aux plus grands rôles
les comédiens de la diversité ont obtenu
près de 13% des troisièmes rôles 16% des
deuxièmes rôle et seulement 8% des
premiers rôles et les premiers rôles ont
le dos large
il suffit de prononcer onze lignes de
texte les loin d'être rendus là où on
voudrait être à radio-canada où là où
les registres et au complet voudrait
être
c'est sûr qu'il n'y a pas dans les roues
le site est dans les premiers rôles
suffisamment de représentation de
comédiens issus de populations qu'on
cherche à jouer lorsque vous regardez la
télé dia ce que vous sentez représenté
au pas du tout pas vraiment mais c'est
aussi pour ça que beaucoup de québécois
qui sont racistes et vont se tourner
vers les hôpitaux des séries ou des
programmes américains parce que
justement ils vont sans scientiques le
plus représenté à l'écran
sur les 894 rôle étudie seulement deux
acteurs non caucasiens ont obtenu un
rôle clé parmi les séries télé les plus
populaires il s'agit de yannick hoël
doit légaré et de cynthia ou maheux
ça bouge tranquillement
mais ça bouge il faut les former se sait
sauf qu'il faut les former
cc oui il ya une fois par génération
quelqu'un qui sort d une école qui est
formidable mais comme sa grandeur mais
il faut les former
la ministre de la culture du québec est
confiante que la diversité aura de plus
en plus sa place dans les séries télé
les milieux 8 mind va voir l'importance
d'inclure tout le monde pour que nos
créations québécoises reflète la réalité
et on s'envole sommes très confiants le
sujet de la diversité à l'écran est
complexe car il faut du temps et de
l'expérience avant qu'une vedette
émergent
le star système québécois est
principalement constituée de vedettes
blanche
on l'a dit mais il faudra de nombreux
efforts pour renverser la tendance
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal